[Inaudible] have you ever wondered what.
Dinosaurs were afraid of?
What creature in the Cretaceous period made taking a drink of
water? A dangerous gamble.
I'm talking about terror Crocs. No, no, no,
not those Crocs dinos.
Sukus otherwise known as the terror crocodile.
What made terror? Crocs such extreme predators.
If they were still around, why would threaten their survival today?
And were they able to eat dinosaurs bones at all?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if terror Crocs were still alive.
[Inaudible].
About 80 to 73 million years ago.
Dyno sukus ruled over the marshes and swamps and feasted
on unsuspecting dinosaurs. Fossils have been found,
showing that terror Crocs grew up to 10 meters long and
they likely weighed close to five tons.
Just about the size of a city bus.
They had banana sized teeth and jaws,
powerful enough to crush bones, many terror,
crock fossils have damaged teeth leading paleontologists to believe that
terror Crocs chomped on dinosaur balls,
but scientists aren't exactly sure if Tara Crocs were hunters
or scavengers. So if they happen to roam around today,
would they hunt us?
This might surprise you,
but crocodile attacks are actually more common than shark
attacks and they happen around the world.
For many people, the risk of being attacked by a crocodile is a daily concern.
In fact,
thousands of years of crocodile attacks have contributed to our
evolutionary fear of reptiles known as purpose of phobia.
Like our fear of spiders. We've developed this phobia over time.
It's a natural way that we protect ourselves like modern crocodiles.
The dyno sukus was more of an opportunistic predator.
If anything happened to come into its territory,
these giant crux would gobble it up. No questions asked
most crocodiles eat on average 50 meals a year as
ecto therms,
they gather heat from their environment so they don't need to eat as much as
some animals to stay warm.
The Nile can eat up to half its body weight in one meal.
If the terror crock ate this much,
it could eat about 2000 kilograms in a day.
That's about 36 average sized humans for breakfast
Crocodiles have a unique valve in their heart.
It increases blood flow to their stomachs through a special aorta.
This allows them to secrete gastric acid 10 times faster than most
animals. This means that they can dissolve entire animals, bones,
and all as terrifying as it would be to see one of these giants walking down the
street,
it's more likely that they would stick to their natural habitat of marshes,
rivers, and swamps.
So you would need to be extra careful about what do they go fishing.
Even though Tara Crocs could wreak havoc on our marshland habitats,
we still hunt them for their skins and make luxury accessories like
handbags shoes and belts.
Many crocodiles in Africa and parts of Asia are also killed for their
meat. Unfortunately,
the bigger an animal is the more attractive it is to trophy hunters.
But with conservation efforts around the world,
many endangered species of crocodile have managed to survive.
Now, if you think terror, Crocs are scary,
how would your life change if the Megalodon still roamed our oceans?
Well, that's a story for another. What if.